nagy plein air au départ c'est le coup
de coeur pour la région de jeunes
animateurs de colonies de vacances il y
à 22 ans il achète l'ancienne frontière
de la camdiac pour en faire un centre de
vacances et c'est comme cela que les
camps d'ados de la rochelle se
transforme au fur et à mesure en maison
familiale
le confort s'installe aussi à bord un
bar puis l'an dernier un sauna
aujourd'hui 2000 pensionnaires parents
séjournent dans ce chalet dans les
vacances des familles mais ce sont
surtout les classes de neige se fait
ouvrir la maison europe
le bar se transforme alors en selle
d'études mais j'ai plein air c'est une
association loi 1901 au plafond autonome
elle ne reçoit pas de subventions l
accueil qui elle veut finalement c'est
un peu comme un hôtel ou en club mais
les conférences et l'ambiance
chacun y trouve son compte les personnes
qui ont envie de se reposer et puis de
se faire plus ou moins servir ils vont à
l'hôtel
ceux qui veulent le silence le calme et
puis quelqu'un plus grand confort aussi
peut être joint à l'hôtel et ceux qui
veulent rencontrer d'autres personnes
vivre un peu comme ils veulent tout en
étant groupe ait choisi sa maison
familiale où nous autres collectivités
à titre d'exemple il faut compter 100 90
ans pour une pension complète
tout est compris et qu'ils aient forcé
le minibus la garde d'enfants et la
bonne humeur
là on est à